استعدوا فالعلم على وشك الدخول في سنوات
حاره بل ستكون الاكثر سخونه على الاطلاق
في تاريخ الارض فيوم الاثنين الماضي
الثالث من يوليو كان اكثر الايام حراره في
العالم تتجاوز متوسطه 17 درجه مئويه لاول
مره
وسط توقعات بارتفاع درجات الحراره اكثر من
المتوسطات التاريخيه خلال عام 2014
مع ظهور ظاهره النينو المناخيه في المحيط
الهادي المرتبطه بارتفاع درجات الحراره في
العالم والتي بدات للتو الامم المتحده دعت
الحكومات الى السباق عواقب ظاهره النينو
بهدف انقاذ الارواح واقتصادات الدول خصوصا
ان هذه الظاهره ستتواصل على مدار العام
الحالي المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
حذرت ان الفتره بين عامي 2023
ستكون بالتاكيد الاكثر سخونه على الاطلاق
على الارض في ظل التاثير المشترك لظاهره
النينو والاحتباس الحراري النجم عن
انبعاثات الغازات الملوثه التي تسبب بها
البشر باطلاقهم ما يقرب عن اربعين مليار
طن من ثاني اكسيد في الغلاف الجوي كل عام